greetings from podcastville you bad
[__]
uncle joey here uncle joey's joint is
brought to you by
manscapes listen you have you've been a
little naughty this year
but your ass still deserves the best of
men's grooming
let my friends at manscape treat you
with the packaged
gift that's gonna [__] blow you away
i mean the holidays are what
two days away and this is the number one
most wanted
present and manscaped you understand me
the performance
package you've got the weed whacker
you've got this thing's [__] got 9
000 rpms
you've got the lawn mower you've got the
crop preserver it also has a crop
reviver
which i use to keep my balls tip top
magoo
and wrinkle free and they're throwing in
a travel bag
with boxer shorts if you order today
wednesday
the 23rd you understand me make sure
this is the year
your dick is ready to get sucked on
christmas day
so and new year's forget about it they
gotta eat yes
because you're gonna get the little nose
trim to stick it up your ass and then
trim around it with the [__]
lawnmower
who's gonna be better than you you're
gonna open up your legs like the [__]
fountain of youth for some freak you
know what i'm saying
anyway get 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com use promo code joey
that's 20 off and free shipping at
manscape.com
use code joey happy holidays
from my nuts and my dick stick
to yours and your family i love you guys
manscape.com
joey the joint is also brought to you by
addict oh my [__] god i'm back
why because of [__] alpha brain
because of the memory and the focus
you got the shroom tech you got the new
mood
you got the [__] whatever the [__]
that makes you energy i can't think of
it right now
that morning joint kill me but you got
these you're like joey what the [__] is
this
instant alpha brain in a package
comes in tremendous flavors my favorite
is the red ruby
you put it right red ruby grapefruit you
put it right in your [__] little
thing with water you shake it up and
bing bang
who's feeling better than you you got
focus you remember you come back
guys look at episode one of this i mean
that sucked dick
episode 23 ain't gonna be any better but
at least i'm a little sharper and i'm a
little tighter
and my game feels like it's flowing a
lot better listen
alpha brain is so good if you don't like
the product
they give you the money back and you can
keep the [__] product who else does
that in this business
nobody so do me a favor go to honor.com
right now
and press in church or joint and get 10
off your order delivered right to your
house
that's on it.com listen the shroom tech
immune the alpha brain
the alpha brain instant the [__] i mean
listen
it doesn't stop the new mood tremendous
at night to bring it down
and help you calm down before you go to
sleep start the year off with a [__]
bang
you're making your resolutions they
start today not the [__] rhyme
i'm not gonna do coke after the first go
[__] yourself go [__] yourself
you're gonna do coke on christmas eve at
grandma's [__] forget all that [__]
resolutions start today go to honda.com
right now
and preston joint or joey or it's church
really it's church and get 10 percent
off you want to deliver to your house
and don't forget landscape.com let's get
this [__] party started
it's christmas eve and you [__]
got things to do
and people to see i love you
[__]
welcome to uncle joey's joy
[Music]
so
what's happening you bad [__]
uncle joey here
for another fun-filled whatever [__]
type episode
of uncle joey's joint you never know
where you're gonna start
and you never know where the [__] you're
gonna end all i know is it's a beautiful
day to be alive it's the 23rd
we got christmas eve tomorrow with your
families and i just want to touch base
with you
see what's going on between these
[__] doctors
they got me going crazy for this [__]
surgery on the eighth
every [__] day i gotta [__] go to
a different doctor
yesterday i went to my family doctor
who's a real [__] nightmare
i'll tell you what man i i picked him
because he was italian
i thought i was gonna go in there and he
was gonna be a nice little goomba type
guy
this guy's turned out to be a real
[__] panty ass
now i gotta go to another appointment
next week after [__] christmas
today i gotta go [__] this afternoon
and do a stress test
so if you're looking at me now i'm
looking good but in an hour i'll be
green
from stress once they stick to
intravenous in my [__] hand
and then to make it even worse i gotta
go to uncle benny's tonight
and perform which i love going down and
performing but i'm gonna be a [__]
mess like i ain't got enough [__]
problems in my life
just trying to be me and trying to put
this [__] together like i said a couple
weeks ago
i don't give a [__] because this is just
we're just a work in progress but still
it gets to guys like me because [__] i
always want to give you the best i can
give you
and be the funniest that i can you know
i'm saying you can't be funny every day
but [__] it after 29 years you got no
[__] choice
and you got no goddamn excuses you know
what i'm saying christmas is gonna be
simple here this year
i'm going to florentine's christmas eve
keeping it light
and then christmas day we're going to do
a diaz family [__] christmas
just us pajamas and we're going to order
chinese food like jews do that's it
no [__] struggling no [__] driving
around
i'm not in the mood you know that
covodial situations
i got to avoid these [__] things
every time you wake up now
you even do something and you're like ah
maybe i should have done that and then
the next morning you wake up everybody's
waking up
ready for a short throw you wake up in
the morning you swallow you feel like a
[__] hooker
the first thing you do is [__]
swallow is your pissing i gotta make
sure i don't have a [__] sore throat
i gotta make sure i don't have a [__]
headache i don't even know what the
symptoms are
i just i just do everything through my
[__] throat
every time i see people i'm around a
bunch of people there goes my [__]
throat
you know i told you saturdays i went up
to north bergen
and i went to a deli i keep my [__]
mask on and when i go out i keep my mask
on
thank god nobody's actually acting
asking for [__] pictures there's no
picture taking season right now
you want to take a picture go take a
picture of a [__] treat but there's
no pictures there's no hugs
there's nothing i hug people i mean
listen you can't take away the [__]
hug
if a hug is going to give me covered
i'll run with the [__] hug
i don't mind giving the dear friend the
hug if i see him
just look the other way it's like you
know harvin why it's like hugging a
harvey weinstein
you don't want to want to make out with
him right you don't want to kiss him
right in the [__] neck
and then give him a chance to knock on
your door and stick it in your ass later
that night hours
and you got to take him to trial eight
years later i'm telling you he [__] me
well next time
when you're kissing don't kiss him on
the cheek why be international look the
other way when they kiss you in the
[__] face you [__] dummy
you know i'm sick and tired of this [__]
already people you hug somebody
you know i'm not you think i'm gonna
give you an elbow you know i look like a
[__] chicken
i see these people giving elbows and i'm
like listen that's never going to happen
what the [__] is it elbow what is this
muay thai girl
and you're elbowing me in the elbow and
we still got to get down together
and get close to one another so what the
[__] give me a [__] breather
if you're not going to give me a hug
just give me a [__] i don't mind
knuckling nobody
listen i don't think covert grows on
[__] knuckles
unless you're two sticking fingers up
[__] dirt homeless people's [__]
then you gotta worry about coving on
your [__] knuckles you know what i'm
saying but besides that
i think you're gonna be fine i think
everybody's gonna be [__] fine you
know
but i don't want you to think a lot of
people walking around this is what makes
me laugh about life
but a lot of people walking around and
think they're gonna wake up january 1st
and this is gonna be gone some people
think they're gonna wake up
january 21st after president biden takes
over
and this is gonna be gone guys then i'm
gonna stop with this
then i gotta stop they just found the
strain in great britain
some [__] english guy chip chip
charlie ho
he's got a sore throat so now i got to
worry about it
it gives you [__] dirty feet now now
there's another strain
you know enough enough enough
just give us the shot that works all
right now i got to take a shot
in 90 days i gotta do another two shots
and if you do the [__] antibody the
antibodies lasting six to nine months
so you might as well just get the kobe
just go [__] get it
do the hydro crowd all the resin
whatever the [__] it is
they cost you a dollar that's why they
don't want to give it to you know that
right it cost you a dollar so nobody
makes no [__] money
so that's what i want to give it to you
and it [__] works i listen i'm not a
political guy you see a pinfall hat on
my [__] head
not in a million years i'm just telling
you what i'm here i'm just
here to report the [__] facts maybe
if you want to fact
check me fact check me i don't give a
[__] it's a [__] podcast what do i
give a [__]
do i look like bill beutel to you do i
look like some jerk off on scene i don't
i don't get paid to report the news
i just get paid to goof on it goof on
you smoke a joint get the [__] out of
here do the best i can with my life
i'm gonna [__] sit here every week
and watch the news and report the
numbers
wear your mask wash your hands and don't
eat no [__] [__] that don't you
don't know where the [__] it's been
that's it
it's that [__] simple you know what
i'm saying you're gonna smoke a joint
with somebody
that puts you in higher percentages
what's lower percentages like what i do
with uncle vinnie's i don't mind doing a
show for 38 people
but you're out listen i don't want to
see a hundred people not even by mistake
i see a hundred people i start shooting
at them now that's it dispersed
immigration it's like immigration once
i'm scatter
i don't have time for this [__] no more
people i'm sick and tired of all this
[__] just like you guys are
just you guys think that like you know
you're the only ones that have problems
you're the only ones that had a bad year
you're the only ones that lost the
salary you're the only ones that lost a
job
listen what this has taught you is to
adapt you got to [__] adapt i know i
know you don't want to do that
you got to go out of your [__]
comfort zone covert is not here to stop
that i spoke to a 25 year old
kid the other days uh she's a daughter
of a friend of mine
sweet kid but she goes you know covered
uh i can't get a job because of colby
listen if you're going to blame
everything on covert
you're going to have a hard life because
covert is here the next two or three
years
you better regroup get that notebook out
write some [__] goals and see what
direction you're taking this book
you know tuesday night last night i fell
asleep on the couch like at
nine o'clock i was just wiped you know
every time i got to
go to a doctor my anxiety level was high
and after my anxiety level goes low i
just get tired
i must have fallen asleep on the couch
for like an hour
i got up my wife was gone
the kid was sleeping i go and my wife is
halfway away still she's watching some
[__] show that don't make sense
and i lay down i try to lay down next
one also my mind sparked
you know at [__] 11 o'clock at night
my [__] mind sparked
of things that i had to do so i said you
know what let me get up make a cup of
tea
and then we go downstairs and make some
[__] notes about
and what am i doing i'm not making notes
for today ain't nothing going to happen
today ain't nothing going to happen
[__] last monday
and ain't nothing gonna happen the rest
of the [__] two weeks till new year's
eve
i'm getting ready for 2021 you know i'm
starting off with a [__] surgery
i got two shows at venice the fifth and
the sixth
the seventh i'm just gonna relax lift
some weights strengthen up the [__]
muscle
and on the eighth i'm gonna shoot to
that [__] hospital hopefully i'm home
by two three in the afternoon it's my
daughter's birthday
so you know i gotta [__] do all my
weight watching weight lifting
so i could [__] have some points uh
have some carville cake to celebrate her
eighth birthday
i'm looking forward to that she's gonna
be [__] eight years old
how [__] time [__] flies
i just still remember her holding her
and then you know
dancing with her and going to [__] on
a swing and pushing her and now
we have normal conversations it's it's
it's
truly been quite amazing uh
sitting there with her on saturday night
you know like i said watching the
honeymooners and thinking that
i lost my other daughter when she was
five from the divorce
but i'm living the life with mercy that
i want to live with my other daughter
so we're all i'm all avoid you know all
debts are paid that's it we got
i'm doing what i was supposed to do i
got a second chance at it
we're gonna have a great christmas my my
wife got a great treat
you know and uh listen i'm like you guys
if you think i jumping down up and down
around christmas i don't
i lost a mother at [__] 15 16
and christmas has never been the same
but you know what
i come around especially for them i've
been coming around the last year and
every year i get better trust me
i don't like saying i'll tell you how
much i hate santa my daughter hates
santa
i got a picture of my daughter when she
was a year and a half taking a picture
with santa
and we had to keep her away from santa
it was santa my wife
me and mercy on the other side she hates
pedophiles she spots
all those little santas at the [__]
walls they are looking
if they can finger bang one little kid
it's a success for them
they get 30 a day you know i don't trust
those sanders anymore
they're the creepiest [__] they
keep a white beard all year long
they keep that white beard for because
this is their season pedophilia season
is their season
i may be wrong you know me i talk a lot
of [__] i just don't trust those [__]
santas and
walls and [__] something suspicious i
want to see the background check before
my daughter sits on your legs
something ain't right here you got a
little spot by your dick there
these [__] these [__] sanders take
a viagra they'll let your kids sit on
them it's like a lap dance for them
it's [__] horrible but it's true i've
seen it i've [__] seen these santas
i don't even like my daughter [__] one
listen my daughter said to me she didn't
like santa
i was kind of [__] happy i don't like
him too much either i didn't tell her
that but
i've never been too crazy about [__]
santa you know he gives you something
nice he don't even give it to you
somebody else gives it to you
but they gotta [__] your kid if i'm
a kid when i get older like 15 i tell my
man what'd you lie to me those years
what the [__] did you think i was that
[__] stupid
now you you you raise me to [__]
think there's a santa i don't think she
believes in santa no more
i think like it's an unwritten rule she
figured out i haven't rather santa
my wife hasn't said nothing about santa
but for some reason i think that she
already knows she figured it out my wife
took her to buy a gift the other day
who the [__] knows and who the [__]
cares i'm just telling you
get prepared for 2021 that's it but i
don't want you to think january 1st
you're going to wake up and it's like
hey
we're back on the ball breathing on
people [__] you
it's going to be a while it's going to
be phases
and you're just going to have to adapt
and i know you didn't want to do
construction but looks like you're going
to do construction now and i know that
you didn't want to deliver [__] uh
food but you don't have to blow a food
now you're gonna do whatever you're
gonna have to do this is gonna change
this forever
this is gonna change the way we look at
[__] things forever
you know i'm looking at my comedy career
between you and me guys i don't see it i
don't see a comedy career
i mean i know that here in april it's
going to be [__] beautiful
and we're going to be able to do comedy
outside you know
[__] parking lots and trust me i'm
excited for that because april and may
are beautiful here
i got no problems working it out you
know
i know that by september october the
crowds will be coming back
a little bit once everybody gets their
vaccine and everybody gets comfortable
you know people took a beating
psychological beatings on this people
have taken
psychological beatings if you started
this and you had a little
listen a little bit of mental health
issues
this [__] blew it up here my heart
goes out to you
get help talk to somebody call one of
your worthless [__] friends and talk
to them for a [__] hour you don't
have psychiatry money
i don't give a [__] you know guys i i
consider myself well grounded
i consider myself a lot of good things
trust me i'm a lot of bad things too i
have a lot of weaknesses but man
when this pandemic started it took me by
surprise march and [__] april it took
me for a [__] meant the world
it took me to a mental [__]
psychological state
until about august or september when i
started lightening up by doing little
coffees
with rich voss and little things with
gym and little things with friends from
north bergen
and in time it took time but listen you
can't let your guard down right now
i can't have you in the hospital over
the [__] holidays
you know you can't really tell people
how to live their life
you know i i go on facebook i see you
out at [__] clubs
four nights a week i don't want to hang
out with you
jumping up and down with no [__] face
mask you know jim flooring team brought
up a great fact yet there goes i did a
show the other night
and i realized why they close at 10
because at 10 o'clock because when we
get [__] stupid
that's when we start getting drunk and
that's when we start [__] hugging
people hey man i love you
hey man i want to do this hey man listen
i want to do a lot of things with you
guys
i believe in the power of this podcast
trust me i'm telling you
what i believe in the most is that it it
it creates a bond between us it really
[__] does create a bond between us in
the
weirdest [__] way i've never met half
of you guys and you've never met me
but then again i know half you guys from
[__] jay bish to
deborah hubster the [__] uh bob
lalingas you know i know a lot of you
guys
and i just know what you guys went
through this year jay just went through
a horrible
surgery he's recovering you know deborah
hubster's
going to war with the [__] postal
department every other [__] day
you know uh bob lalingus has a job he
work everybody's struggling at some
point
or another maybe not maybe you got a
great job maybe you're doing great
financially
but maybe you're sitting there all day
behind this computer screen for eight
[__] hours
at the end of the day you can't even
[__] blink you're blinking like
somebody poked you in the [__] eye
this has affected all of us so don't
take none of this [__] personally
and don't think it's just [__] you
and that the world is picking on you
i get like that sometimes like i've got
like this maybe four days
when they reclose mercy school and [__]
like this
this is just something we gotta go
through guys that's it and that's that
and we'll get through this
you know but i understand the covert
thing like i said i was gonna do a new
year's thing with jimmy and uh
and uh rich foss at one of the clubs and
listen to clubs don't even want to open
they don't want to risk it for 25
30 people it's not even worth like the
[__] new years
but i still wanted to do something for
you on new year's maybe just come online
for 20 30 minutes smoke a joint with you
you know
so we consider all these options we get
away with the [__] we
you know i don't want to drive back at
[__] 12. i don't know what's going to
be out there
i don't know a [__] you just don't
know
so everybody here is going day
to day the most important thing i need
for you to do is
to relieve your stress there's no
dentist prison
you haven't paid rent tell the landlord
to suck your dick
time to suck your dick right through his
face what's he gonna do i think the
moratorium ends
in a week or two so i don't know like
the building on fire i don't know
i don't know what the [__] to tell you
but everybody's struggling to the
[__] [__] is
now 2121 is about hope
it's about hope it's my personal hope
you know but guess what
this whole 2121 should have been
following what you've been doing already
is working on your strengths whatever
strengths you have
whatever weakness that you you have work
on that
you know i i worked on little things
myself little things that i had going on
now
you guys know i was in a bad place when
i left
l.a i mean look at the last 10 episodes
of the church
and look at me now there's been a
gigantic change and look at the episodes
from april and march there's been a
night
a tremendous change a huge weight has
been lifted off my shoulder
the best thing i ever did in my life
listen i've done
a lot of bad things but i've done maybe
three good things is one of them was to
get my family out of there
and how do i see it by what the [__] is
going on in l.a right now
it's it's it's not good i miss it i miss
my friends i wish them well i spoke to
dean this morning
i speak to ryan secular you know me i
spoke to
steve simone down in florida he's down
there getting ready to buy a house
listen
we all had to adapt to different
situations
don't feel like this is all about you
and you got to be careful man you know
a lot of people don't see that yeah you
may get it
and bring it home and get somebody and
yes the percentage rate is low
the the whatever rate of transmission is
low you know here it is
you know i know that la has become the
epicenter
i know that boston is second and i know
that [__]
tennessee memphis the hospitals are the
your rooms at 95
so it's spreading taking care of
yourself you know
i hate to talk about this but you have
to from time to time because it was out
in the news
and i wanted to talk about the other day
you know people are getting
in trouble for people calling out people
there comes an age where you don't do
things
that just listen if you go out and drink
right now
and get in the car and you get drunk and
get a dui
it affects you a little bit when you're
young
a couple weeks you're on a bus your
friends pick you up
they drive you when you get to 32 33 34
and you got a wife and a kid
you get drunk you get a [__] dui
a lot of people get affected now
your grandmother has to come your father
your mother-in-law has to come
and take your kid to karate you know you
just
so life is about how much your decisions
affect how many people when i went to
prison yeah i went to prison it affected
[__] me it's not till i was in prison
but i realized when people
come to visit me to look on their faces
the look on their faces was [__]
heartbreaking
because they hated seeing me sitting
there with an orange [__] suit on
hey i get it so when i went to prison
i affected 10 people i disappointed 10
people
so every decision that you do in your
life
as you get older as you start having
more responsibility
it [__] you know it affects more
people
and you don't even know it you don't
even know i know that the podcast
affects people in positive ways
sometimes and i know that i get emails
that it affects people in negative ways
sometimes
nothing you can do you know when you
have uh 250 300 000 people watching you
per episode you're gonna have
people that are not going to like it and
you're going to have people that are
really hit home with
that that's the main thing not everybody
is always going to be happy
with your decision but you know last
week i was
reading this thing i know you all read
about it with tom cruise going off on
the set
a [__] mission impossible [__] 19
or whatever people are pissed off
tom cruise shouldn't have spoken like
that you know five of the [__] quit
on the [__] set you know what are
they gonna do now go work at spotify you
know i'm saying like
you know nothing bothers me more than
the la mentality
i did not do well in l.a especially when
i stopped doing blow you know
why because i told you what was on my
mind
i didn't give a [__] there was no there
was never a filter
but once i stopped doing the coke that
little fear of not being able to do coke
by addiction
then there was no filter and then i
would tell you exactly
what i thought how i felt about it
whether you liked it or not
oh and then once i got married my train
of thought changed again in 2009
and then i had mercy in 2013 and boy did
people start hating what i had to say
because i'm going to tell you what the
[__] it is because
that my decision not only affects me now
and my wife but it affects my [__]
seven-year-old [__] daughter tom
cruise is trying to make a movie the
[__] franchise believes in him
this franchise this studio whatever the
[__] it is i'm not gonna sit here and
tell you i don't know what the studio is
but this studio could have said no we're
going to push this movie back to all
this cove it is over
so somebody has to go in there and say
to them listen
this is what i want to do and i will
give you my word that i will make this
[__] work okay now
let me tell you guys a little something
that you guys don't know
that you don't read behind the the
background
when covered started and shut everything
down but once production
got back going sag decided you ready for
this
my union screen actors guild who's been
great great insurance
all this thing they did something that
like i said
some people's decisions you like and
some people's decisions
you don't care to like and i get it
that's why there's vanilla
and chocolate that's why there's
[__] and dicks you know what i'm
saying
you don't want to suck a dick you could
always take it in the [__] you got
[__] options okay
so sag went a look
and looked i don't quote me on this this
is what i just heard
and then i saw it and i didn't know for
sure
when this went down when covert went
down everything shut down for a few
weeks
but then sag sent out an email the
people don't make a lot of money and say
i don't know what the number was you
know eight thousand nine thousand
a year doing screen actors guild work
and they sent the name i wanna i wanna
know how you would feel guys
they sent an email because i know you're
on
you're all hard-working people a lot of
years ids
a lot of user bartenders but a lot of
you is also a blue collar
okay and i want to know
how you would feel about this so what
they did was
they called a bunch of actors
that weren't making you know anywhere
near to a [__] living
which you know 30 percent of the actors
in la uh
make what a living is the other [__]
70s starved to death
so they contacted you know just actors
that weren't making much money and they
said hey
hi how would you like to be
work closely with producers and
directors
okay now let's talk from the heart here
there's some actors you have to be very
very very intelligent
to act at some levels when you see the
the the guy that played batman the
[__] english guy
you know when you see people like alfred
molina
when you see people like john bernthal
those are people who [__] study
they wanted to access the time they were
[__] sex that's just the way life
works out
but in that way you got these people
that watch so
i'm not live they got money they go out
there and all they know i want to be a
laptop i mean
actor you didn't even write out why you
wanted to be an actor and how you will
become an actor
they just go i want to be an actor i
want to be an actor i want to be after
they sign
they pay all the doe for acting class
and guess what nothing never happens
why do you think well i'll tell you as
nicely as i can
because they're [__] morons they've
never watched a tv show that they
uh you know they just think they're a
hell of a man
i want to be a hacker and they end up
[__] waiting to sing
then they end up [__] being away then
it's always a bad ending
when you want something you have to go
after like i did i didn't want to be a
[__] actor
do look at my face do i look like i
wanted to be a [__] actor
but when i got there i had to make money
so i [__] got up every wednesday and
i got the l.a
[__] weekly and i sent them
submissions and i acted but i didn't
want to be a [__] actor
it was just something that i didn't mind
doing and i thought it was cool to do
from time to time then i realized i had
to do it
to keep my [__] insurance so
what they [__] did was they sent out
emails
how would you like to meet directors and
producers and work with
the best actors in the business and all
these people raise their hands
and they said yay because god forbid
you know there's no [__] desperation
yay
and these guys said okay you're going to
become covet
agents and they're like what but i'm an
actor or something don't worry about it
what you do is you take some type of
[__] course
online 72 hour like it's like
maybe a three hour read do not quote me
on this i don't know exactly what this
is and you get certified and now you get
400 a day to work on
a set how much do you know
about [__] colby it's like when you
go i never went down but i just heard
from friends who did go there
when you go to dodger stadium to get a
[__]
covet test or any of those mass places
do you think those people
are really nurses are you [__]
you can't be that stupid that people
they hide to give you a [__] swab
to put it in your nose and put it back
you know
there's a chance for human error human
errors like what 8
7 something to do with that and then
the people that are giving you that test
not for nothing
they might be a [__] [__] too they
might put your test until the set
gonzalez's [__] name
and now you're walking around thinking
you've got coco with no symptoms and
you're asymptomatic so
this whole thing is confusing for me
when listen when i when i go to buy weed
i want to buy weed from the girl i want
to tell me everything
whatever i do i want to go to the
[__] source okay i want
what i'm trying to say is i want to work
with the best people that i'm available
to work with okay now
again i pay commissions on my acting
work
plus i pay union dues every [__] year
and listen guys i'm telling you right
now
those union dues are not [__] light
they bang you out every [__] three
months and if you don't pay those
[__] union dues
you're not allowed to shoot i think you
look at what it's called you just get a
call and say hey you're uh
they call it something you're f66 or
some [__]
and you're not allowed to [__] work
until you pay your [__] dues trust me
i'm telling you
they won't let you step on that [__]
thing if your [__] dues are paid
not one [__] time so even though i
don't work
i still [__] pay my dues even my
wife's like why the [__] are you paying
your dues they sent a bill out
i mean a lot of actors were pissed they
went on social media
like how dare you send the bill out when
you didn't [__] face but anyway let's
get back to the [__] covet story here
so what you're telling me is what you're
telling me is
you're getting four out of work actors
to be [__] covered
uh whatever the [__] you call them and
they have
no experience to covert have you
well we hire why don't we go halfway why
don't we hire a nurse's practitioner
and three assistants i can live with
that
three women who'll tell you listen you
can't stand so close
mask on mask off if you're not working
you have to go back to your trailer
i did it with the sopranos with the many
saints in newark
and it worked perfectly everybody there
they just hired a company but see people
are going to be cheap during this
[__] pandemic
you know producers are gonna try to save
money with kinky [__] companies and
[__]
and everybody's gonna end up getting
[__] sick my man
the african-american brother and uh
tyler
whatever his name is tyler perry you
haven't heard a complaint from his
[__] camp
because he did he did the nba before the
nba did it he did the acting bubble
before the nba did it you don't have no
complaints from running in tyler perry's
[__] shows
i would work for tyler perry in a
heartbeat if he called me
because it's a thing of [__] trust so
getting back to tom cruise
he has his movie already got shut down
one time
okay i don't know how many [__] days
because the crew member had [__]
covered
so he just throws a tantrum not even a
bad tantrum
it wasn't like the [__] irish girl
what's the english guy that played
batman
when he went off on everybody and called
them all a bunch of [__] names
it wasn't even as bad as that it wasn't
even a third as bad as johnny depp's
[__] little fit
downtown it wasn't even a fit he was
just explaining that listen
this is what this movie how much [__]
you know how much a day it costs
to produce those mission impossible
movies close to two hundred thousand
three four hundred thousand a [__]
day to do those [__] movies
so if you blow three or four [__]
days that's 1.2 million dollars now
i'm not a financier i don't give a [__]
about financing i don't have financing
for movies
but i do know one thing i love human
beings
and if you're gonna get involved in a
movie i want you to listen
i've done a thousand two hundred dollar
a day movies hundred dollar
day movies those are the movies and they
couldn't get the exact amount
of financing but that person wants their
dream
to be out there but for their dream to
get out there they're going to cut all
the [__] corners they can
and now i got to come work for you while
you walk we've got a couple more corners
i don't like working with people who cut
corners
i never [__] have there's always
going to be and especially
during a pandemic i got an offer to work
in wilmington north carolina
i don't know these people you know two
days on some [__] what i read was
[__] ass
wipe [__] so i'm not gonna go to north
carolina to work with a bunch of people
to stay at some [__] motel six where
i'm in danger bringing back [__]
covet
getting it from somebody or giving it to
somebody
you know i get a lot of [__] for the
[__] podcast
right now we're in no position to bring
guests into this [__] house a friend
of mine
can i come over and be a fly on the wall
i thought you'd be a fly on my nuts
nobody's coming over i don't want nobody
over here at all not
for christmas i want nobody over here
mike is my brother mike wears a mask
mike goes home mike ain't now jumping up
and down with a bunch of jerk orbs
you know free the yugoslavians who gives
a [__]
now is not the time to be out there
jumping up and down to free whatever the
[__] of this mind your goddamn business
so when i hear tom cruise's rant about
eight
guys what the [__] you do it again
you're [__] gone this is enough we
already shut this [__] movie down
the quicker we [__] shoot this the
quicker we get this [__] over with do
you understand it is the way i looked at
it
hey when i shot the [__] soprano
movie the many saints in newark
it was a great experience i'm not gonna
lie to you wearing the mask
taking it off the people were a little
heavy duty but guess what
i lived to tell another [__] day they
even sent somebody down here
after the movie was finished to give me
a covet test to
to make sure that this system is [__]
working
like i said stand up comedy you could
suck my dick because i know half your
[__] clubs
half of you [__] are filthy by
nature instead of naughty by nature you
filthy by [__] nature okay
and now you're keeping your clubs open
they're in this [__] pandemic
when there's more [__] [__] to be
afraid of and more [__] to be weary of
and you're still creeping your clubs up
and closing
steam them i want to make sure you for
me to step into any [__] club
they better have an ultraviolet night
and a light at night
that stays on while the gym is closed so
it kills all that stuff
they better have the best in amp
purifiers that's the only way you're
going to get me in your [__] comedy
club right now that's it
and a small [__] amount of people i
don't give
a frenchman's [__] i'm just trying to
[__] work on my art
and keep sharp i don't know i don't know
my stand up is [__] weak i don't even
know what i'm gonna say tonight at
vinnie's
i've been working on things but i don't
know it's not too [__] good
at least i'm honest with you at least
i'm not sitting here going i'm killing
every [__] day [__] those [__]
thank god i'm away from that [__] but
anyway
you can't get mad at a guy like tom
cruise
for [__] being mad you know act or
whatever
he's protecting his interest he was
saying what needs to be said
and i listened to it twice and i giggled
about it i'm like
go tom cruise johnny scientologist
i'm good then two days later i read
george clooney stuck up for
he just said he would have done it a
little differently which
i also appreciate also somebody pulls
you aside
and says hey man but you know what
that's the problem with that like
you can't say nothing to anybody
because once you say something to
somebody you become what they call
abusive god forbid you say something to
somebody on a set in l.a
right away oh my god he said things
i've never heard before and that's what
those people are saying now
just to back up something right now and
if you don't believe me i'll
i'll give you names i got a dear friend
ricky cruz out of miami
opened up for me and the boy god a
couple years ago great kid
known him for 20 years he was ricky cr
he was
uh tom cruise's body dab on rock of ages
i know tom cruise does 20 000 movies
ricky cruz's
is isn't the worst one he's ever done
the one that they tortured him for the
most
so ricky doubled him
i talked to ricky about tom cruise
didn't say a negative thing about him
said the guy was great he'd bring me
smoothies every day on the set
as a matter of fact i know 10 other
people
just just a short number that have
worked with tom cruise
zit problems they found them to be
pleasant they found them to be great i
know a girl that told me the best two
people she ever worked with
was cameron diaz and tom cruise cameron
diaz took a [__]
dc for the weekend and south beach for
the weekend
these actors are good people when they
work with you and they know that
they're making a lot more money than you
are and when they see that you're
[__] hustling they take care of you
on the set
not that they give you an envelope but
they ask you if you think they bring in
sushi
whatever they try to make your life more
pleasant i've always heard great things
about tom cruise
always always let's forget about
scientology
and sucking travolta's dick i don't know
that's got nothing to do with me
i don't know about travolta i do know
about tom cruise and what i've heard hey
man
let me tell you something if i had a
movie franchise
and i'm getting you know 50 million
dollars per movie
and i'm in charge of 300 people
on a [__] set guess what
[__]
i'm gonna say some [__] from time to
time
because you are responsible it's the
same reason why i haven't been on a
plane to [__] all these states
that are wide open yeah that's great
they're wide open
i know you've got a socially distanced
i know nobody nobody's got nobody's got
covered everybody got a test yesterday
i know no no nobody's got nothing you
know what before we go to all that
[__]
let's just shake hands and part friends
let's just assume that
everybody in this [__] got
covered and i'll see you [__]
next year okay
when happy has got the vaccine you got
the penguin shot into your arm
whatever the [__] you want to do you can
do it's got nothing to [__] do with
me
but for right now when you call me to
[__] make an offer you better have an
ultraviolet light
air filters i want to hear the whole
[__] plan on paper
so i can sign it and you can sign it and
if there's a misunderstanding
we'll see each other in court because
you're putting people's lives in [__]
danger
you know it's not 11 people office a
movie usually has
200 people on a [__] set that's a
[__] super spreader and they just had
to cancel the movie somewhere and moved
it to another [__] location
so what do you want for tom cruise to
say what do you want to say hi guys well
can you know what the [__] are we
talking about here you
[__] dummies let's separate and happy
is like joey here i'm tom cruise's
[__] dick no i'm not
i don't want to be in a tom cruise movie
i've never i don't give a [__] about
movies anything no more
i'm just telling you the reports that
come out of la and how people act when
you call out you know
when you just say something to them hey
just separate oh my god
he he did this i had that explosion
speech
and a lot of people like well he had a
bad day they didn't have a bad day
he was protecting his [__]
investments you got to look after your
friends if not why [__] have them
you got to look after the people you
work with if not what happened
you're not looking up to that guy what
if he has [__] grandmother he goes
home
and his grandmother [__] dies it was
all because of your nonsense and your
stupid movie
because i had to do something for your
[__] dream
go [__] yourself i walk up on you you
know it's like some guy one night i was
at uncle vinny's
you know eddie trunk was in the room i
did something that i would never do
under circumstances
some kid knocked in the door with three
cocktails in him
looked at me and trunk and jimmy
florentine and he goes
i want to talk to you you and you when i
get a minute and i go do me a favor get
the [__] out of here lock the door
and they just slam the door in his face
i'm a catholic
i don't slam my doors in nobody's face
unless they're a jehovah witness
i don't do that type of [__] but
it's coving what are you knocking on the
[__] door for you know exactly what
i'm gonna [__] say to you
i'm gonna say something that's not gonna
be very [__] nice
it's colvin we did a show we entertained
you
we got to see each other you know what
if i take a picture with you
i gotta take a picture with your other
38 people i might have a chance of
[__] getting something
or might not get something so better yet
let's just shake hands apart friends
but that's it before you're gonna
[__] attack poor tom cruise
go [__] yourself he's just this is how
people need to act
fifteen hundred dollar fine if you get
caught without a face mask in cuba
ain't nobody in cuba got 1500 so guess
what
everybody wore a mask have you seen the
numbers for cuba lately
google yeah but joey they're a time in
this country what the [__] are we
becoming
the [__] are we becoming
i can smell those fidel fatigues in the
air
you can't smell them closed at 10
no school you know close the beauty
shops
you can't sing at thanksgiving fidel
you're starting to smell fidel a lot
more than what the [__] you are so what
are you talking about
what what two thirds they they they
want us to [__] go tommy or whatever
the [__] they want us
it's our job to say go [__] yourself
but that that that's not the [__]
situation at hand
the thing i'm talking about is
protecting the people around you and
that's what tom cruise did
i got nothing but love for that
[__]
i love him in collateral i love him in
the one where he played the [__] drug
dealer [__] plane i love him and i
i love the guy i don't care about a
scientist i love them in vanilla sky
with cameron diaz
say whatever the [__] you want you got
to protect your own especially during
these times of colvin
if you're not going to do that close
your [__] business up and quit
i don't give a [__] you're going to
starve anyway the [__] death
you got to look after the people in your
lives you know christmas eve
you know look around do you really want
to be in a place where 19 [__] people
you haven't taken the test
you don't know for sure yeah i'll go
someplace there's 20 people
but i'm going to take a test so i know
i'm not the one
and as a matter of fact i probably take
two tests
i'll probably take two tests i know i'm
taking the test tomorrow again
i'm gonna take a test before christmas
eve just what the [__]
my insurance pays for it what do i give
a [__] get tested
don't go stand on the line with 300
other people that are breathing
even if you leave you're going to test
positive that they're going to send you
an email
saying you test positive at those sites
randomly huge sites
don't go to those [__] places go to
an urgent care pay the 35 hours whatever
the [__] it is
and you'll be well off and that's it and
that's that
it's [__] christmas man it's
christmas
i think writing is free right it is free
again you get what you pay for if you go
to rite aid you don't know what the [__]
you're gonna get it's free
they might [__] you know again you
get what you pay for
i don't know what your plans are and i
don't know what you're thinking i don't
know what situation
or your mental stability is but i do
want to wish you
guys and all your families a happy
[__] a merry christmas
i want this christmas to be [__]
extra special
this christmas should be extra extra
special
and you're sitting there going jerry why
is it extra special i got no money i
gotta know this i got no job
this is why it's extra special because
it teaches you that the people in your
life are worth more
than what you put value on them for
they're just not some [__] schnooks
you're gonna go to the house
on thursday night or friday and you're
gonna see what real love is without
you know it's a [__] uh pandemic
people are down so i want you to do me a
favor this week man guys
you know this is the time of the year
where you see people
going around you know moving from here
to here doing this doing that
you know but you know what man they're a
little [__] nicer when they're doing
it do you notice people they smile at
you
it's the [__] holidays man
again the next couple days try to make
somebody's day
smile keep a door open for them
you know tell them you'll help them
carry that whatever the [__] it is
this all goes to the universe the
universe is watching
2021 you're gonna need the universe more
inevitable
you're gonna have to call in on so many
karmic favors that you did over the
years
whether it's not kick a dog whatever the
[__] it is
you're gonna [__] call on all the
karmic favors you did
the best thing you could do is forget
about what you're going through forget
about what's in your pocket forget about
what you're not getting
and think about what you do have and how
lucky we have that we're still alive
we still have each other i'm sure a lot
of you has lost loved ones this year
and i'm very [__] sorry about that he
can't bring him back
it's what we can do to move forward from
the joint from uncle joey's joint
from my man mike and one by one podcast
we want to wish you a merry [__]
christmas
uh you know a great weekend we'll worry
about new year we'll burn that bridge
when we get who gives a [__] about new
year's
christmas is special tonight new year's
is amateur night
for a bunch of people to go out and get
raped maybe maybe they'll let harvey out
on new year's
with gisele maxwell whatever her [__]
name is
those two [__] pedophile [__]
but no pedophiles no nothing straight
love
from my family to yours from mike's
family to yours
from one by one podcast from yours and
from the uncle joey's joint to yours
we wish you a merry merry [__]
christmas patreon
i'm happy you got the [__] shirts oh
[__] i made them come true for you
you guys uh have no idea
what you did for me in july and august
by answering your [__]
you know emails by making me produce
content
you guys kept me there i love doing my
patreon three
five ten dollars i don't know what i'm
going to do with the
shirt tier i want to keep the prices low
especially now
[__] netflix went up to 17 [__]
dollars
you know now you got to pay for this
that so
i'm trying to keep your prices low for
next year
if you want to buy a shirt you can buy a
[__] shirt
if not you know do what you need to do i
appreciate you being around
it gives me a chance to express myself
with the reefer show the album of the
week
my morning motivations i do two joey
diaz projects on there which i love
doing those podcasts
because i'm able to play around with
some music and explain to you a little
bit more
about my knowledge for it my love and my
passion for music i want to thank you
guys i want to thank you
for making this possibly one of the best
christmases i'll ever have
because of all the bad [__] that's going
on we're going to make this christmas
[__] good
merry christmas thank you guys i love
you and thank you for watching uncle
joey's joint stay black dogs lovers
all right you bad [__] are two
days away from christmas obviously
you got one shoplifting day left but
what are you going to do about that i
can't help you out with that
but i want to thank you i want to thank
you for uh having our backs throughout
the year
having my back welcome and mike
you know just uh understanding what's
going on like i said
this podcast is a work in progress but
before we get the [__] out of here
i want to talk to you about something
that's very important to me hygiene
men's hygiene is very important beside
my fungi toe i don't have a lot of
problems you understand me
you know why because i shave my balls i
clean
my helmet i put i use uh [__] lotion
you know so my skin don't get dry i work
i do it every day i can
but the most important gift you can give
yourself this year it's manscaped why
because if your dick looks like a
[__] hurricane went through it
with hairs all over the place women
ain't gonna want to suck that
i mean you're having problems already at
least show up with a [__] great dick
listen
you want a ten thousand piece ass you
can't show up with a ten dollar looking
dick
that looks like it went to some [__]
uh you know
hurricane [__] looks like puerto rico
after the hurricane
you don't need that [__] so right now
today you're gonna go to
manscape.com and you're gonna pick up
the performance pack and you're like
joey what's your performance package
the performance package starts off
number one
with this right here you're like joey
what's that this is the lawnmower 3.0
the best trimmer known to man [__]
kind you [__]
wipe around your little dipstick and
your nut sack with this
and if you want to have your wife scrape
your ball sack or
if you're gay do the same i don't know
somebody somebody will help you out
shaving your [__]
this is tremendous landscape number two
the performance package also gives you
the weed whacker
i love this [__] thing i love this i
trim my [__] with it and then i put
it in my nose
and sniff my nose hairs as they chop
away it's a two-for-one
right there nine thousand [__] rpm
motor
and a blade that moves at 360 degree
degrees to clean out the [__] nose
pubes
the covert dust and god knows what else
you got your filthy nose your disgusting
hepatitis c looking [__] you
also get
the crop preserver which is [__]
tremendous
and you get the crop reviver the
preserve is a ball deodorant
i don't need bald deodorant i want that
natural patois in my nutsack
but the reviver that's like [__]
unless i put in uh
wrinkle cream on for women you put that
on your nut sack it's better
listen it's either this is a preparation
that's your appropriation h on your ball
sack
it looks like a baby's [__] head you
know what i'm saying it's tremendous
this is a lot better the reviver plus
you get a gift bag and a pair of travel
shorts
this year end of the year by taking care
of you
manscape like your uncle joey get 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
use promo code joey that's 20 off
of and free shipping at manscape.com
use promo code joey happy holidays from
my nutsac
to yours you suckers and you know what i
bet manscape would do a [__] pleasure
for a women's little monkey you shave
her on that [__] [__] right there
right above the [__] you leave it open
you leave some hair like a little patch
you don't want the [__]
it's like a toupee for the [__] you
know what i'm saying the church up to
the church the choice
is also brought to you by honor one of
my all-time
personal favorites been with them since
day [__] one
alpha brain the flagship of the
operation
why do i say that because if you buy
alpha brand you don't think it helps you
they'll give you your money back and
they keep and they keep and you keep the
product
nobody else does that you ever go to
session one place a chinese joint
they don't [__] if you don't like the
food they give it back to you [__] no
they tell you to go [__] yourself and it
doesn't do that
when the company does that that tells me
you have belief
and it also comes out our brain also
comes an instant
in case you don't like pills and
capsules tremendous flavors
ruby red grapefruit and we also have
shroom tech immune shroom tech sport new
mood
listen add it is the future that's why
it's called on it go to honda.com right
now
look at the great line of products they
have and get back to me chuck sucker all
right
this is the way you're gonna start off
your year healthy
[__] i don't know if you're gonna be
wealthy healthy which is the most
important thing you can't
get the wealth unless you have your
health so it all starts with your
[__] mind and your insides
i love you guys very much i want to
thank honor again i want to thank
manscape for having her back and
watch the video i [__] trim my ball
sack and i throw hairs at people
that's what you do you trim your ball
sock and you keep putting the hair in
there
there wasn't a lot of hair in the
[__] baggie this year because i stay
on my [__]
i trim my nut sack every two weeks and
i'm saying so
take care of yourself give yourself a
little manscape for christmas get
yourself a little alpha brain for
christmas
and you start the new year right i love
you guys merry christmas
enjoy your families and i'll see you
[__]
monday morning tip top magoo ready to
[__] go
stay black
that's it no covert here conceptus
[Music]
so
you